convert 37 centimeters to meters let me
write this over 37
and i'll write centi in a different
color to emphasize the prefix 37
centimeters
and we want to convert it to meters so
we really just have to remind ourselves
what the prefix centi means
centi
literally
means one over a hundredth or 100th of a
meter so this is really saying 3 700
meters so let's write it that way this
is literally 37
hundredths of a meter
so 100
meters
these are equivalent statements
so what are 37 hundredths
of a meter well that's going to be 37
hundredths of a meter that's going to be
hundredths of a meter
of a
meter
which can be rewritten as if you wanted
to write it as a decimal that's zero
point
you could view it as three tenths and
seven hundredths or thirty seven
hundredths so zero point three seven
zero point three
seven
meters
another way that you could have thought
about this is look i'm gonna go from
centimeters to meters i have a hundred i
need a hundred centimeters to get to one
meter so i'm gonna have to divide by a
hundred in order to figure out how many
meters i have and you should always do a
reality check if i convert centimeters
to meters should i get a larger number
or a smaller number well however many
centimeters i have i'm going to have a
fewer number of meters meters is a
larger unit so you should have a smaller
value here and it should be a smaller
value by a factor of a hundred so you
literally could have started off with 37
37 centimeters let me write it this way
centi
centimeters
and actually go let's go through a
couple of the units right over here now
if you wanted to turn it to decimeter so
this is 1 over 100 decimeters 1 over 1
10. so you would divide this would be
3.7 decimeters
let me write this is 3.7 decimeters
decimeters
and a decimeter is one tenth of a meter
so you divide by 10 again so this is
0.37
meters
meters so one way to think about it is
to go from centimeters to meters you're
going to divide by a hundred dividing by
a hundred you would move the decimal
space over
to the left two times doing it once
divides by ten doing it twice divides by
hundred so you get to zero point three
seven meters